Now that we've heard from Mora about the benefits of alternate
bandwidth, let's try it for ourselves. Looking at the histogram we created
earlier, we can see that it's skewed. We've just zoomed in
on the left side of the graph from the histogram from before.
Working from his new histogram, let's add some better labels and
some binning. To adjust the binwidth, I can pass the binwidth parameter
to QPLY. And for this data, I'm going to choose a value of
25. That seems pretty reasonable since we're going from zero to 1000.
The other thing that I want to do is break up this x
axis every saved 50 units. To do that, I'm going to pass the
breaks parameter to our scale to x scale continuous layer. Breaks is
going to take a sequence that has a starting point, an ending point,
and a step or the interval space we want on our axis.
So in this case, I'm going from zero to a 1000, and
I want to step every 50 units. You can learn more about
how to manipulate the scale and the breaks on the x or y
axis by reading the link in the instructor note. When
I run the code I can see that I get
a completely different histogram. Taking a closer look, it's easy
to see that many users have less than 25 friends.
These users are probably new. Now let's ask a more
interesting question. Which gender group on average has more friends
men, or women? To answer this question we need to
split this histogram into two parts for males and females.
Let's see if you can do that.